So back to what i was saying before my theory
oh god um steve rogers did not have a girlfriend
before he went into the service says who
the history channel so he becomes captain
america and from that moment on a symbol of
america he is rushed to the front lines he
becomes a war hero then he is frozen in ice
right so based on everything you've told me
um after he gets unfrozen he goes from
world-threatening disaster to world-threatening
disaster that's when he's not a fugitive
from the law right so it seems like he was
pretty pretty busy all you're doing is
repeating everything that i've already
told you about my friend and colleague
obviously captain america was a virgin
In the marvel cinematic universe the people
are protected by two separate yet equally
important groups the heroes who save them and the
attorneys who clean up their collateral damage
but only one can be both this
is her story dun dun lawyer show
she holds illegal comedy like
we've never done before all rise
he's back now amen all right calm down
what's fun is the types of marvel characters that
come to her for legal advice no judge is gonna
take this seriously unless we do things by the
book oh the book of his chantey no the book of
american uh loss it's a law show like allie mcbeal
or the practice and then it breaks all those rules
the fun of the show is to combine this
legal world and all of the possibilities
around superhero weirdness call my lawyer
i just want to be a normal anonymous lawyer
we're really pushing boundaries other
shows haven't before case closed
Welcome back everyone this will be my
brand new she-hook marvel video they just released
a new trailer and a bunch of new clips and it
looks like they're combining a lot of the planet
hulk world war hulk elements with her origin story
so we're getting a lot of the backstory that they
cut out for thor ragnarok we'll break it all down
i'll be doing videos for all the episodes when
they start next week it literally starts next week
so be sure to subscribe to get all those videos
i'll do a special marvel giveaway during that too
we'll start with disney plus memberships all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
all your theories about them incorporating this
planet hulk storyline to the origin story and
this is all from episode 1 this one clip here
just starting with the footage because they answer
like a long-running fan theory while making a joke
about captain america being a virgin so the funny
thing is that they actually just did something
similar when ant-man addressed the thanos theory
in a brand new video that they shot at marvel
hi i'm scott lang um well you might know
me as ant-man and i am hopeful the wasp
look before we start let me address the
elephant in the room i've heard a lot of
chatter out there asking why i didn't shrink down
go in and uh kill thanos in a really creative way
first of all gross secondly it's much more
complicated than that allow me to explain if only
we had the time if you don't know what the
famous theory is that was a big thing back
during avengers infinity war and avengers end
game people were wondering why didn't ant-man just
shrink down go inside thanos's butt and grow real
large and use that way to kill him like literally
use a backdoor method to make as many jokes
as possible to kill thanos the answer for the
ant-man question was him just saying ooh that's
gross and two it doesn't work that way but it is
them addressing that in now they're addressing
the theory the captain america was a virgin for
pretty much his entire life right up to the end
of avengers end game when he went back in time
to stay with peggy carter like that's when he
finally got it on the funny thing about that is
that the writers of avengers end game were also
the people who wrote the other captain america
movies so they had been thinking about captain
america's backstory in the mcu for a long long
time they said even though it's not canon in their
own minds like in their own theories as writers
they said they felt like captain america got it
on with a woman during the uso tour when he was
stopping at all these different cities across
the u.s when he got the super soldier serum but
before he'd started his relationship with peggy
carter like before they had become a thing there's
still be tons of fan theories about that too but
it's just like a funny way of marvel addressing
fan theories so if you like that marvel is now
canonizing a lot of these crazy fan theories about
all the different characters they're probably
going to continue to do that in series like this
usually it's easier to do this in series where
marvel can make fun of themselves like deadpool
is a good example when deadpool comes into the mcu
in deadpool 3 you can make a lot of jokes about
stuff like this but the other big thing going on
here in this origin story is they kind of clarify
how she gets her powers like what is the accident
that causes the car to crash where she eventually
gets dose with hulk's blood accidentally but
as you probably noticed the ship that fires
on them that's powerful enough is literally the
exact same type of ship as the grand master ship
which is where we get to our planet hulk storyline
because during thor ragnarok they kind of combined
some elements from the planet hulk comic book
story line with a new thor story during the planet
hulk storyline the illuminati since the hulk is
just becoming too much of a problem so because
they feel like they can't kill the hulk they
don't want to kill the hulk because it's their
friend bruce banner the illuminati who we just saw
in the 838 universe and doctor strange too decided
that they're going to banish him to outer space so
they just fire him in a spaceship to outer space
but the ship crashes on the planet zakar and a
warlord is ruling the planet and forces him to
fight as a gladiator in the pits this is where the
plot of thor ragnarok became very very different
but the idea in the mcu is that when he was on
sakar fighting in the grand masters tournament
he was full hulk like the hook had completely
taken over and subsumed the banner personality
so when banner finally came out during that
movie he's like wait a minute what happened the
last thing that he remembers was long before the
events of him landing on the planet so the idea is
that just like the planet hulk comic book story
line hulk had a son or multiple sons he has two
sons in the comics while he was on sakar in full
hulk form and that's why banner doesn't remember
that he has sons the biggest character people
think of when they think of hulk's son is skaar
he's the son of hulk and one of the local women
that hulk fell in love with there's also this
storyline with something called the old power
that's contained inside the planet which is sort
of like this cosmic power source that galactus
eventually wants because it's such a big deal
skaar is able to access it and it just makes him
even more powerful so like the whole idea is that
he becomes even more powerful than the hulk
eventually but what happens in the comics is
that hulk's wife dies and he goes back to earth
to get revenge on the illuminati that he thinks
killed her all the while thinking that his wife is
dead not knowing about his son still being alive
so the idea in the tv series is that somebody
is coming back from sakaar to try and kill the
hulk and she-hulk just gets caught in the middle
of that like they're not here to kill she-hulk
they're here to kill the hulk and remember when
you see him in the car when they attack him he's
still got his arm in the sling he's got this
green light on his wrist that looks like it just
monitors his transformations like his rage level
for those of you also asking how can they actually
injure the hulk like wouldn't he transform and
wouldn't it heal all that damage i think the
idea is that the weapons that they're using on
him in his current state just allows for that to
happen because his arm looks totally healed in
later episodes i think they'll explain how this
transformation like this event causes him to heal
that damage when he transforms into hulk again
you can let me know in the comments though like
who from sakaar is using this ship like grand
masters type of ship to come and kill the hulk
like who on that planet would want to kill the
hulk for those of you that also want a world
war hulk storyline in the mcu they're just
like reasons why you'd have to explain why the
hulk would get so mad that he get out of control
one of the ways to do that would be
something happening to his son in the mcu
the other big clip is just she-hulk doing all the
law and order jokes because it is kind of a lawyer
show they make the she-hulk titles in the style
of the law and order titles and even use the law
order theme song and when they talk about
the two different sides in the mcu like
you have superheroes and then the damage they
caused and the lawyers who clean up the damage
and how there are only a few people who can
do both she-hulk being one of those characters
because she's both a superhero and a lawyer by
day just like matt murdock daredevil which is why
obviously he's such a big part of the series makes
so much sense that they would actually include him
but bruce banner hulk having to tell her like
no no this is going to be a big problem for you
like literally somebody comes in a spaceship from
the planet cigar to try and kill me because of my
power eventually they're going to try and do that
to you too thunderbolt ross his people even though
obviously william hurt passed away in the mcu so
r.i.p he will be missed there's still all that
storyline they set up with him going after the
hulk now that they have she-hulk his successors
like val for instance val's probably gonna take
a lot of that thunderbolt ross storyline will
be coming for she-hulk to take their power when
kevin feige talks about the funny aspect of the
series with the different types of characters that
come to her for legal representation that's him
just sort of referencing all the crazy cameos that
they get to do from the comics and from previous
mcu properties daredevil being the best example of
that also all the wong stuff like you see a longer
version of him coming to see her like look i want
to sue somebody and her having to explain to him
like okay if you want to sue somebody in american
court you have to go by the rules of the american
law even though the avengers handle world-ending
threats like thanos for instance because they're
still trying to operate above board and as part
of society they are subject to a lot of society's
rules which is when thunderbolt ross comes in and
tries to tell them what to do like okay there are
sanctions on you now you either have to sign
this sokovia core document or you have to go
home that's really where you get to things like
the thunderbolts but because episode 1 is dropping
next week my full videos will start posting after
they release it remember they moved episodes
to thursdays so that the star wars episodes for
andor and the she-hulk episodes for all the marvel
stuff don't drop on the exact same day be sure to
enable alerts for my channel so you don't miss any
of those episodes there were a couple other big
things that were released this week so i'll try to
do videos for those as quickly as possible while
you wait for that everyone click here for my other
she-hulk daredevil trailer video and click here
for my loki season 2 first look video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!